well if you think about it for a minute
you'd really begin to realize that for
thousands of years women were really
economically dependent on man and that's
just the way it was I mean in fact if my
grandmother or great grandmother were
alive today she just wouldn't even
believe the way the world works and the
way women have really gained economic
power I think if you go back to the
1960s you begin to see the early signs
of that because baby boomer women were
the first generation in mass to get that
education and education was really the
key for women succeeding in the
workplace not just entering the
workplace but staying in the workplace
and getting really some pretty good
earning power back then very few women
prior to the baby boom generation had
that opportunity but this generation
went in there made it happen and
education really has been sort of at the
heart of what's allowed women to really
gain that economic power that is
transformed their role in society for
now and well into the future
what's so interesting to me is that
while women were gaining their education
for the very first time in history we
saw our economy transform itself pretty
dramatically we went from an economy
that was in industrial manufacturing
based where brawn really defines your
role and gave you the power to really
earn income to a more knowledge-based
economy where the skill set was more
education based so women got that
education at exactly the right moment in
history that allowed them to really
succeed in the workplace today for the
very first time we see a critical mass
of women entering the workforce with
that education and gaining earning power
in fact what's so incredible is that if
you were to look over the last 30 years
what you would notice is that men's
income has remained rather flat if you
adjust for inflation whereas women's
income has grown exponentially now of
course some of that is just trying to
catch up and we're still not all the way
there there is still a lot of work to be
done but women have gained incredible
incredible power economically and
they're beginning to take that power and
translate it into all kinds of
interesting ways of doing things
different than the way men have
what we begin to understand as we see
large numbers of women with earning
power is that women in fact do use their
money differently than men in fact it's
been noted even in developing countries
that ninety percent of women take their
income and they reinvest it in their
families and their communities while in
those same developing nations only about
thirty to seventy percent of men take
that money and reinvest it in families
and communities they have a tendency to
spend it on alcohol and tobacco so you
know it doesn't sound really great on
the surface but that's just really the
truth in developing countries but even
in the United States what we notice is
that women have a tendency to spend
their money more on their family more on
education on health and on things that
really make life for families a little
bit better that's good news